les deux faces d'une même médaille il ne
saurait y avoir de reprise économique
sont confiance et de confiance sans
notre capacité à lutter avec efficacité
contre cette épidémie est notre système
sanitaire pour bien fonctionner a besoin
d'une économie solide
mon message ce soir tiendra en trois
mots transparence prévisibilité et
responsabilisation transparence dans
l'accès aux données dont nous disposons
comme chaque semaine les prévisions les
modélisations l'état de la situation
sanitaire territoire par territoire
prévisibilité pour donner des outils aux
français pour savoir vers où l'hiver où
ils vont en fonction du lieu de vie dans
lequel ils résident
et puis responsabilisation parce que
dans cette lutte que nous menons cette
lutte acharnée contre la diffusion du
virus nous détenons chacun de nous une
part de la victoire par nos
comportements individuels et collectifs
par l'attention que nous portons à
chaque instant de notre quotidien à ne
pas transmettre le virus autour de nous
un point épidémiologique
d'abord la situation sanitaire
continuent hélas de se dégrader en
france c'est aussi le cas dans de
nombreux pays voisins certains sont dans
une situation sanitaire plus dégradée
que la nôtre et d'autres pays ont amorcé
une reprise épidémique
hélas depuis quelques jours ou quelques
semaines
il ya donc en france chaque jour de plus
en plus de personnes contaminées
de plus en plus de personnes malades et
de plus en plus de personnes qui font
par conséquent des formes graves avec un
impact hospitalier qui augmente
trois indicateurs rapide que vous
connaissez le taux d'incidence d'abord
en population générale
oui cette courbe qui augmente avec une
incidence à 116% mille c'est à dire que
pour cent mille personnes en france 116
sont actuellement porteuses du virus
symptomatique ou non
deuxième indicateur c'est le fameux
facteur de reproduction du virus le r
c'est à dire combien de personnes je
vais contaminé si je suis malade en une
semaine
je rappelle que si le r tombe en dessous
de 1 ça veut dire qu'on est efficace et
qu'on freine l'épidémie s'il est au
dessus de 1
ça veut dire que l'épidémie continue
hélas d'évoluer je rappelle qu'au
printemps dernier le r était aux
alentours de 3 si j'étais malade je
risquer de contaminer trois personnes en
une semaine
aujourd'hui on estime aux alentours de
1,1 1,2 selon les indicateurs ça veut
dire que si je suis malade je risque de
contaminer 1,1 ou un ou deux personnes
troisième indicateur c'est le taux de
positivité des tests sur 100 tests que
nous réalisons combien sont positifs 9%
9 % c'est un taux en augmentation et
c'est un taux élevé à titre de
comparaison lorsque nous avions réalisé
le déconfinement dans le pays ce taux de
positivité était aux alentours de 1%
pourquoi je vous parle de ces trois
indicateurs parce que ces trois
indicateurs nous permettent de
déterminer des seuil d'épidémie d'e
seuil de gravité de la diffusion du
coronavirus sur le territoire national
et s'essaye nous ont permis à eux mêmes
de déterminer ses fameuses zones dites
zones d'alert sur lesquels je vais
revenir rapidement
d'abord la zone de circulation active
lorsque le virus commence à circuler on
dit que l'incidence est supérieure à 50
cas pour 100000 habitants la zone
d'alerté renforcée lorsque le virus
circule davantage et qu'il circule aussi
chez les personnes vulnérables ou
considère les personnes âgées de 65 ans
et plus la zone d' alerte maximale
c'est lorsque le virus circule vraiment
beaucoup en population générale chez
chez les personnes vulnérables et qu'on
enregistre un impact sanitaire
conséquent avec un taux d'occupation de
nos réanimation à l'échelle d'une région
de 30% par les malades du coronavirus et
enfin l'état d'urgence sanitaire qui ne
correspond à aucun territoire à date sur
le territoire national et qui correspond
à au moins 60 % des malades en ré a
atteint de corona virus je vous rappelle
qu'il ya quinze jours nous avons classé
marseille et la guadeloupe en zone d'
alerte maximale
il y a quelques jours paris également à
basculer en zone d' alerte maximale les
mesures vous les connaissez la fermeture
totale des barres un protocole rang
forcés dans les restaurants par exemple
on ne peut pas être plus de six
personnes sur une même table dans un
restaurant les espaces entre les tables
et les chaises de deux groupes
différents sont augmentés et les
restaurateurs sont amenés à vous
proposer d'inscrire vos coordonnées pour
qu'on puisse vous rappeler si d'aventuré
un cluster et est identifié dans ledit
restaurant il est fondamental que chacun
participe quand je parle de
responsabilisation c'est cela que chacun
participe à ce protocole sanitaire
renforcée qu'il n'y a pour seul objectif
d'éviter des contaminations groupées
dans ces métropoles il y a deux semaines
nous avons également classé bordeaux
rennes rouen et nice en zone dite d'
alerte renforcée c'est le niveau
d'alerté en dessous avec cette fois ci
une fermeture des bars prononcer à 22
heures l'interdiction des grands
rassemblements au delà de 1000 personnes
et la limitation des regroupements y
compris sur la voie publique en dessous
de 10 personnes à nouveau pour augmenter
la distanciation sociale et éviter que
le virus ne circule davantage la
situation s'est dégradée dans plusieurs
métropoles
ces derniers jours qu'ils vont nous
conduire à basculer un certain nombre de
métropoles dans des zones d'alert
supérieur tout d'abord s'agissant de
dijon dijon que vous voyez apparaître a
maintenant un taux d'incidence un taux
d'incidence chez les personnes âgées qui
justifie son classement en zone d'
alerte renforcée
de la même manière que clermont ferrand
a une incidence en population générale
une incidence en populations vulnérables
qui justifie son classement en zone d'
alerte renforcée pour ces deux
métropoles
ce passage se fera dès samedi matin
ensuite la situation est encore plus
dégradée dans d'autres territoires
lille tout d'abord voulait voir
apparaître sur l'écran avec une
incidence très élevé une incidence chez
les personnes vulnérables également très
élevé et vous le voyez un taux
d'occupation des réanimations par des
malades atteints du coronavirus qui a
atteint les 30%
grenoble présente les mêmes
caractéristiques c'est à dire un taux
d'incidence cumulé en population
générale en population vue
érable et une part de malades atteints
du coded en réanimation supérieure à 30%
la situation s'est également dégradée
pour lyon où l'incidence a dépassé
également les cotes d' alerte et la part
des patients en réanimation à l'échelle
régionale et donc la même qu'à grenoble
c'est à dire supérieure à 30% et enfin
saint-etienne qui présentent peu ou prou
les mêmes caractéristiques épidémique
pour ces quatre métropole lille grenoble
lyon et saint-etienne un passage en zone
d' alerte maximale a été décidée par le
président de la république en conseil de
défense et de sécurité nationale ce
passage sera effectif à compter de
samedi matin par ailleurs deux autres
métropoles présente des caractéristiques
épidémique inquiétante
il s'agit d'abord de toulouse avec un
taux d'incidence qui n'est pas encore
arrivé à la cote d' alerte maximale et
une part de patients en réanimation qui
augmentent et qui pourrait franchir les
30% dans les prochains jours par
ailleurs vous voyez les traits bleus qui
correspondent à au taux réel
d'occupation d'airé à part des malades
qu vide alors que les très vert
correspondent aux modélisations vous
voyez que la situation sanitaire s'est
aggravée un peu plus vite qu'escompté à
toulouse
et c'est également le cas pour
montpellier qui sur la diapositive
suivante avec là aussi une dégradation
sanitaire qui nous font craindre le
franchissement des 3 indicateurs dans
les prochains jours pour toulouse et
montpellier
à l'instar de ce qui a été fait pour
paris la semaine dernière nous nous
donnons quelques jours d'observation
pour vérifier si la situation sanitaire
se dégrade et si les indicateurs sont
franchis une bascule en zone d' alerte
maximale pourrait être opéré d'ici à
lundi matin
pour l'ensemble de ces métropoles les
élus locaux ont été consultés beaucoup
d'entre eux la plupart d'entre eux ont
été reçus par le premier ministre au
cours des derniers jours
l'ensemble de ses élus ont été contactés
par le préfet le directeur général de
de lagence 2 régionale de santé de
manière à les alerter sur la dégradation
des indicateurs épidémique et leur
annoncer que la bascule avait hélas de
grands risques d'être opéré et dans les
prochains jours donc avant la mise en
place pratique de cette bascule
la concertation se poursuivra entre les
préfets les dg de rs et les élus pour
déterminer le périmètre d'application
territorial de ces mesures et la nature
précise de ces mesures
malgré cette situation difficile et ces
annonces difficile je tiens à préciser
qu'il ya aussi des signes d'amélioration
dans plusieurs endroits du territoire
national il faut aussi prendre les
bonnes nouvelles quand on peut les
observer signe que les mesures que nous
mettons en oeuvre pour lutter contre la
circulation du virus et que les mesures
qui sont prises d'ailleurs par les élus
locaux de même pour freiner la diffusion
du virus sont efficaces ainsi la nièvre
et le morbihan quitte les départements
classés en zone d' alerte et on
enregistre une amélioration sensible de
la situation sanitaire à nice à bordeaux
une inflexion positive également être
observée à rennes ainsi qu'à aix
marseille
je le dis tout de suite avant de crier
victoire il faut avoir suffisamment de
recul être sûr que dans la durée
la circulation du virus se réduit et que
dans la durée
l'impact sanitaire sur les hôpitaux se
réduit il n'est donc pas à date de
bascule dans une zone d' alerte
inférieurs pour les villes que j'ai
cités mais nous surveillons cela
quotidiennement et nous espérons pouvoir
annoncer des bonnes nouvelles peut être
la semaine prochaine pour alléger des
mesures il faut être sûr qu'elles ont
été suffisamment appliqués et qu'elles
sont efficaces pour éviter un effet yoyo
deux reprises épidémique si on allait
j'ai trop tôt au-delà de ces
informations je voulais je le disais
appelé à la responsabilisation
quand je dis que chaque français peut
agir contre la diffusion du virus
c'est que nous devons être vigilants
dans tous les moments de notre quotidien
c'est difficile c'est un effort
permanent
je lui ai dit la semaine dernière quand
on porte le masque et qu'on fait
attention aux personnes qui sont à côté
de nous dans le métro au travail au
restaurant
ce n'est pas pour relâcher les efforts
quand on rentre chez soi à la maison
hélas les hôpitaux et les réanimations
en particulier hospitalise beaucoup de
malades qui ont été contaminées dans un
cadre familial est en réalité ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que les malades
qui sont aujourd'hui en réanimation ont
été contaminées il y a deux semaines par
des gens qui ne savaient pas eux mêmes
qu'ils étaient contagieuses souvent
parce qu'ils étaient plus jeunes est
asymptomatique et eux-mêmes c'était
contaminé quelques jours auparavant par
exemple dans les bars hélas ou dans des
rassemblements festifs ou non est en
fait ce passage du virus des personnes
jeunes qui font peu de symptômes et qui
sont en général peu sensibles aux virus
vers les personnes vulnérables se fait
souvent dans un cadre familial même si
vous souhaitez recevoir vos proches même
si vous souhaitez recevoir des amis même
si vous recevez votre famille vos
enfants vos petits enfants
vous devez garder de la distance vous
devez porter le masque et faire
extrêmement attention autour de vous
parfois un écart d'une heure dans une
semaine où on a fait attention suffit
hélas pour tomber sur une personne qui
était contagieuse sans savoir et se
retrouver soi-même quelques jours ou
quelques semaines plus tard à l'hôpital
un mot également pour paris vous l'avez
peut-être entendu ce matin le directeur
général de l'agencé régionale de santé à
déclencher le plan blanc dans l'ensemble
des hôpitaux franciliens
qu'est ce que ça veut dire le plan blanc
ça veut dire que la part de patients
qu'aux vide en réanimation dans les
hôpitaux franciliens augmente et que la
pression sanitaires se fait de plus en
plus forte dans les hôpitaux parisiens
et franciliens en général obligeant à
des programmes et des soins puisque
canton des programmes une chirurgie
programmée
imaginez une chirurgie d'une prothèse de
hanche pour de l'arthrose par exemple eh
bien on peut libérer un bloc opératoire
éviter d'occuper un lit de réanimation
et parfois même transformé le bloc
opératoire en salle de réanimation
donc à mesure qu'on augmente nos
capacités d'accueil hospitalière on peut
le faire on peut monter jusqu'à 12
milles libraires mais à mesure qu'on
augmente nos capacités de l'animation on
est obligé de déprogrammer de retarder
des soins utiles voire indispensables
pour des gens qui ne sont pas atteints
du coronavirus est par ailleurs à chaque
fois qu'il ya un malade en réanimation
il y à un malade qui fait une forme
grave ce n'est pas neutre ne suffit pas
de se dire qu'on a des lits de
réanimation pour pouvoir faire face
notre objectif c'est qu'il y ait le
moins possible de patients en
réanimation et pour cela il faut qu'il y
ait de moins possible de malades qui se
contaminent et enfin mon dernier message
sera pour les soignants de notre pays
qui sans relâche mois après mois jour
après jour font face à la première vague
d'abord à cette recrudescence épidémique
désormais je veux leur dire le soutien
de la nation toute entière nous sommes
avec vous dans la lutte que vous menez
les décisions que nous prenons qui sont
difficiles et qui impacte la vie de
nombreux français sont des décisions que
nous prenons pour protéger les hôpitaux
pour protéger les français
nous tenons à vous soignants nous vous
remercions pour votre mobilisation de
tous les instants et j'en profite pour
rappeler celles et ceux qui le peuvent
également à rejoindre les renforts à
travers la réserve sanitaire ou les
plateformes régionales pour venir prêter
main forte notamment dans les ehpad
mais également dans les hôpitaux et
enfin un mot aussi pour les soignants
qui en ville se bat avec cette épidémie
qui font partie de ces premières lignes
à mesure que la prise la pression
épidémiques augmente les soignants sont
soumis également en ville un travail
toujours plus fort et intense donc un
merci pour les soignants je vais passer
maintenant la parole à bruno le maire
merci cher olivier mesdames messieurs
voudrais tout d'abord m'associer aux
mots que olivier vers ans vient d'avoir
pour les personnels de soignants je peux
en témoigner personnellement nos
personnels soignants sont
exceptionnelles dévouement de
compétences de courage et de
professionnalisme comme olivier verront
vient de l'indiquer
nous sommes confrontés à une
recrudescence de l'épidémie dans un
certain nombre de territoires qui nous
oblige à prendre de nouvelles mesures
sanitaires qui sont rigoureuses mais qui
sont nécessaires mesures sur des
fermetures de bar sur des règles
sanitaires dans certains restaurants me
jure que aussi un impact sur l'activité
économique de notre pays
les français sont inquiets de la
situation sanitaire
mais s'ils sont tout aussi inquiets de
la situation économique et nous voulons
répondre avec la même force que celle
que nous avons eue depuis le début de la
crise aux préoccupations de tous les
français sur cette situation économique
je pense évidemment à tous les salariés
je pense aux dizaines de milliers d'auto
entrepreneur de commerçants d'artisans
d'indépendants en particulier dans les
secteurs qui sont les plus touchés par
les conséquences de la crise
l'hôtellerie la restauration les cafés
les salles de sport le monde de la
culture le monde de l'événementiel ou
associé à l'événementiel je pense aux
photographes au fleuriste au graphiste
au traiteur aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup
moins de mariages beaucoup moins de fait
très peu de rassemblements en moins de
fleurs à commander moins de photographe
en activité - de graphistes pour envoyer
des cartons d'invitation moins de
traiteur et bien nous voulons
accompagner chacune de ces professions
depuis le début de la crise nous avons
fait un choix clair avec le président de
la république et le premier ministre
protéger au maximum les salariés comme
les entreprises
ce choix je tiens le redis elle nous a
permis d'éviter des centaines de
milliers de licenciements et des
dizaines de milliers de faillite en
france je le dis avec beaucoup de force
à nos compatriotes nous continuerons à
protéger les salariés et les entreprises
tant que la crise sanitaire sera là et
nous continuerons d'adapter les
dispositifs à la situation sanitaire et
aux contraintes qui peuvent en découler
pour le monde économique
l'un des instruments les plus efficaces
pour faire face à cette crise économique
et soutenir les très petites entreprises
les indépendants les commerçants ça a
été le fonds de solidarité que nous
avons mis en place dès le début du mois
de mars
il a concerné 1,7 million d'entreprises
pour un montant total de dépenses de
plus de 6 milliards d'euros
il a associé l'état et les régions que
je tiens à remercier pour leur
engagement
mais nous voyons bien aujourd'hui que ce
fonds ne permet pas de couvrir toutes
les situations qui résulte des nouvelles
restrictions sanitaires
nous avons donc décidé d'élargir et de
renforcer le fonds de solidarité
ce fonds de solidarité comme vous le
savez il est réservé depuis le mois de
juillet au secteur du tourisme de
l'événementiel de la culture du sport
mais certaines activités en étaient
exclus alors qu'elles sont directement
impactés par les conséquences de la
crise sanitaire
nous allons donc inclure ces nouvelles
activités
je pense aux fleuristes je pense aux
blanchisserie qui dépendent très
directement de l'hôtellerie et de la
restauration
je pense aux bouquinistes des quêtes
paris puisqu'il ya moins de touristes à
paris aujourd'hui je pense aux arts de
la table puisqu'il y a moins de
restaurants ouverts je pense aux
graphistes nous allons ajouter au total
75 mille entreprises qui vont pouvoir
bénéficier de ce fonds de solidarité
elles sont 150 milles en bénéficier
aujourd'hui elles seront 75 milles
supplémentaires avec l'élargisse
ce fonds de solidarité en deuxième lieu
cette aide du fonds de solidarité était
réservée aux entreprises de moins de 20
salariés c'était bien l'objectif au
départ soutenir les plus petites
entreprises soutenir des
auto-entrepreneurs soutenir les
indépendants nous allons élargir cette
aide à toutes les entreprises jusqu'à 50
salariés
toutes les entreprises des secteurs
d'activité que je viens d'indiquer ce
fonds de solidarité pour en bénéficier
il faut soit faire l'objet d'une
fermeture administrative soit avoir
perdu 80% de son chiffre d'affaires
beaucoup d'autres repreneurs nous ont
dit 80% c'est trop strict il faut que
vous baissiez ce seuil
nous avons donc décidé de baisser ce
seuil jusqu'à une perte de 70 % de son
chiffre d'affaires vous voyez que ces
modifications sont profondes
nous élargissons le nombre de
bénéficiaires de ce fonds de solidarité
nous le portons aux entreprises jusqu'à
50 salariés dans les secteurs que j'ai
indiquées et pour en bénéficier soit
vous êtes fermé soit vous avez perdu non
pas 80% mais 70% de votre chiffre
d'affaires je rappelle que pour pouvoir
bénéficier de ce procédé rites et les
dispositifs sont extrêmement simple il
suffit de vous rendre sur le site
impots.gouv.fr et c'est sur une simple
base déclaratoire que vous pouvez
bénéficier de ce fonds et je rappelle
que la semaine dernière nous avons
décidé de porter l'aide du fonds de
solidarité de 1500 euros à une aide
mensuelle qui ira jusqu'à 10000 euros
c'est donc un renforcement massif du
fonds de solidarité qui est proposé
aujourd'hui pour tenir compte des
conséquences des règles sanitaires
nouvelles qui vont s'appliquer à tous
les secteurs de l'hôtellerie des barres
de la restauration de la culture de
l'événementiel ou du sport
le deuxième élément de soutien massif
c'est l'activité partielle le chômage
partiel a permis d'éviter des centaines
de milliers de licenciements et je pense
qu'il est conforme à l'idée que nous
nous faisons notre modèle social
il faut protéger les salariés
protéger des compétences c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui nous permettra de
rebondir plus vite
ensuite parce que nous ne serons pas
priver des compétences qui ont été
touchés par la crise toutes les
entreprises des secteurs du tourisme de
l'événementiel de la culture du sport
pourront bénéficier d'une prise en
charge du chômage partiel par l'état à
100% avec zéro reste à charge pour
l'entreprise jusqu'à la fin de l'année
2020 cela permettra à ces entreprises de
faire face aux difficultés sanitaires
enfin la dernière mesure ce sont les
exonérations de charges sociales les
entreprises fermées administrativement
ou qui font l'objet de restrictions
horaires peuvent travailler jusqu'à 22h
par exemple pour les bars et qui font
une perte de chiffre d'affaires d'au
moins 50% sont exonérés de toute
cotisation sociale jusqu'à ce que les
mesures de restriction soit levée et je
tiens à signaler que les nouvelles
activités dont je viens de vous parler
la blanchisserie les arts de la table
pourront bénéficier de manière
rétroactive des exonérations de charges
sociales sur la période qui couvre le
mois de février au mois de mai 2020 donc
toutes les entreprises qui désormais
bénéficient du fonds de solidarité qui
ont bénéficié de cet élargissement
bénéficie également des exonérations de
charges sociales de février à mai 2020
dont elle n'avait pas pu bénéficier
auparavant c'est aussi un effort très
important
un mot enfin toujours sur ces mesures
sur les questions de trésorerie parce
que je sais que c'est une préoccupation
majeure de beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprise qui se disent nous avons
contracté un prêt garanti par l'état il
est un taux particulièrement attractives
0 25% qui inclut la garantie de l'état
on arrive au bout de ce prêt il va lui
falloir qu'on prolonge la durée de ce
prêt parce qu'on peut pas le rembourser
tout de suite parce que les chiffres
d'affaires ne sont pas suffisants nous
voulons le prolonger quel va être le
taux je confirme que le taux sera au
maximum de 2 5% et qu'il sera compris
dans une fourchette entre 1 et 2,5 pour
cent pour les tpe et les pme
et que cette fourchette de taux de 1 à 2
5% qui est particulièrement attractive
inclut la garantie de l'état qui
représente un point là dessus donc ce
sont des taux qui sont particulièrement
attractifs pour ces très petites
entreprises
et cpm pour les entreprises qui
souhaiteraient bénéficier de fonds
propres je rappelle qu'elles pourront
bénéficier à partir de janvier 2021 nous
continuons à travailler là dessus
deux prêts participatifs de 7 ans
minimum
un taux qui reste à déterminer l'intérêt
de ces prêts participatifs c'est que ce
sont des quasi fonds propres ça ne pèse
pas sur l'endettement des entreprises
donc elles pourront se remettre à
investir ce qui est absolument essentiel
pour notre économie
un mot pour conclure d'abord pour
remercier toutes les fédérations
professionnelles tous les chefs
d'entreprise tous les indépendants tous
les commerçants tous les artisans avec
lesquels nous travaillons main dans la
main depuis le début de la crise ça a
été ma méthode depuis le premier jour de
la crise économique
rencontrer tous les acteurs
toutes les semaines pour évaluer les
dispositifs et les corriger pour
répondre à leur demande et c'est ce que
nous faisons aujourd'hui en présentant
ses annonces sur le front solidarité
d'activité partielle des charges
sociales ou les prêts et garanties par
l'état
ces discussions qui ont permis d'adapter
des dispositifs et de les rendre les
plus efficaces et les plus opérationnel
possible et j'ai personnellement un
souci constant d'efficacité de
réactivité pour protéger nos
entrepreneurs et s'il faut à nouveau
dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent ajustez tel ou tel dispositif
pour qu'ils soient plus efficaces et
qu'ils répondent à la préoccupation d'un
entrepreneur sur le terrain nous le
ferons et je veux dire à chaque
entrepreneur qui nous écoutent et à tous
les salariés qui travaillent avec eux
que j'ai une conscience intime de ce que
cela peut représenter pour un
restaurateur qui a fait des efforts
considérables qui a acheté des vitres en
plexiglas qui a modifié sa carte qui
s'est équipée en masques en gêne pour
ses salariés de devoir à nouveau
compléter encore ses règles et je sais
qu'il y a
et je parfois beaucoup de désarroi
parfois du désespoir parfois de la
colère que nous comprenons ces
sentiments mais que nous voulons y
répondre par des décisions efficaces et
rapides
et comme ma porte est toujours ouverte
pour ajuster ces dispositifs les
corriger et les rendre encore plus
opérationnel
je veux dire enfin que ces mesures de
protection ne nous empêche pas de
compléter la relance qui elle ne peut
pas attendre la relance économique doit
se faire maintenant j'entends les bons
conseils des uns et des autres qui me
disent c'est jamais maintenant il
fallait le faire plus tôt où il faudrait
le faire plus tard bien moi je vous dis
que le bon moment c'est maintenant c'est
maintenant parce que c'est maintenant
qu'il faut investir
c'est maintenant qu'il faut relancer
notre activité économique
c'est maintenant qu'il faut préparer les
emplois de demain en particulier pour
les jeunes générations et de nous
pouvons plus attendre un seul instant
pour engager cette relance économique ce
sont les investissements de maintenant
qui feront les emplois de demain ce sont
les investissements de maintenant qui
feront la compétitivité de notre
économie
demain et ce sont les investissements
maintenant qu'ils nous permettront
d'accélérer la transition écologique et
d'accélérer la décarbonation de notre
économie
vous le voyez ce que nous voulons faire
avec olivier verrons je pense qu'il ya
un caractère très symbolique notre
présence à tous les deux ce soir c'est
de conjuguer la lutte contre le virus et
le redressement de l'économie française
nous allons devoir vivre avec le virus
il est là et il ne va pas disparaître du
jour au lendemain il faut nous en
protéger c'est le sens des mesures
annoncées par olivier véran mais il faut
dans le même temps travailler produire
protéger nos emplois préparer l'économie
française de demain je vais vous dire ma
conviction profonde
nous y arriverons la france a tous les
ressorts économiques personnel culturel
pour faire face à cette crise dans les
meilleures conditions et en ressortir
plus fortes
donc les questions aux internautes une
question de philippe du personnel et ils
mobilisés dès maintenant pour aider les
hôpitaux les ehpad le personnel étant
mobilisation permanente depuis la
première vague dans les hôpitaux et dans
les ehpad
nous ne sommes pas restés les bras
croisés quand je dis nous c'est
l'ensemble des soignants ou dans les
hôpitaux dans les ehpad qui ont engagé
un programme de formations souvent
d'ailleurs de la formation pratique de
personnel à destination des services de
réanimation par exemple et au cours de
mes déplacements j'ai pu voir
d'innombrables infirmier ou infirmière
qui faisait une autre activité que
travailler en réanimation et qui sont
venus faire des stages pour se préparer
pour le moment venu si jamais la
situation sanitaire devait l'exiger
mais dans les ehpad en particulier nous
avons besoin de personnel supplémentaire
et les épidémies arrive n'y a pas que
coville il ya aussi on en parlera à la
grippe qui arrivera dans quelques mois
il y a les rhinopharyngites tous les
bobos qui accompagne l'automne et
l'hiver qui peuvent éloigner des
soignants de leur lieu de travail c'est
pour ça que nous faisons tout pour
renforcer les effectifs et permettre
aussi aux soignants fatigué de pouvoir
se reposer donc cette mobilisation de
tous elle est nécessaire à tous les
instants et nous travaillons évidemment
pour renforcer les hôpitaux et les ehpad
une question de laurent
pourquoi fermer les bars et les
restaurants qui respecte le protocole
sanitaire alors que les transports sont
bondées sans respect des mesures
sanitaires
je comprends parfaitement la question
mais elle fait d'ailleurs le lien avec
notre présence conjointe à bruno le
maire et moi même quand je dis que la
situation sanitaire et la situation
économique sont les deux faces d'une
même médaille
les transports les transports en commun
c'est le moyen d'aller au travail
le moyen souvent d'emmener ses enfants à
l'école les moyens d'aller étudier à
l'université les transports sont
indispensables dans pour la vie
économique et la vie sociale de notre
pays
nous sommes là dans une ce qu'on appelle
une politique de réduction des risques
le risque zéro ne veut pas exister dans
les transports et comme vous
certainement je vois par endroits des
images de rames de métro qui peuvent
être bondé assez à certaines heures
la réduction des risques ça veut dire
sans supprimer les transports et nous y
travaillons et jean baptiste djebbari en
particulier travail à ces questions-là
faire en sorte qu'en respectant les
gestes barrière en ayant les mains
propres en audit et en utilisant du gel
hydroalcoolique
en gardant le masque en toutes
circonstances en faisant attention on
prend les transports en commun et à côté
de cela la question des bars hélas elles
posent plus de difficultés parce que des
études montrent et 7 a testé il ya des
clusters qui sont identifiés qui est des
lieux de contamination et les lieux de
contamination d'aujourd'hui sont les
malades dans les hôpitaux dans trois
semaines je vous donne un exemple qui
concerne pas un bar mais qui vous
expliquera le raisonnement la ville de
zurich par exemple a enregistré il ya
quelques semaines alors que la situation
épidémique était plutôt calme
l'apparition de clusters c'est à dire
des des zones groupe et de malades chez
des danseurs de salsa
non pas que les danseurs de salsa soit
pas de quoi que ce soit mais il se
trouve que le virus a pas mal circulé
j'aï danseurs de salsa zurich ayant
objective et cela a voulu enrayer la
vague épidémique qui s'annonçait a
interdit les fans de salsa de la même
manière qu'eux ils avaient fermé les
discothèques quand il avait enregistré
les premiers groupes de cas et ont ainsi
pu être pleinement efficace là haut nous
identifions des situations
particulièrement à risque
et là c'est encore une fois comme l'a
dit bruno le maire sait pas c'est pas la
faute de qui que ce soit c'est pas la
faute il ya des situations qui hélas se
présentent des risques et il est très
compliqué d'isoler le petit café où on
va être chacun à la table avec des
distances respectables et les bars qui à
partir d'une certaine heure notamment du
soir et la nuit se remplissent sans
respect des distances avec en plus
parfois la consommation d'alcool qui
rend parfois le sentiment d'être encore
plus invulnérable que ce qu'on est et
c'est là aussi qu'on enregistre beaucoup
de contamination donc à chaque fois des
situations sont très à risque
on prend les devants pour protéger les
français mais on ne paralyse pas la vie
économique et la vie sociale de notre
pays une question de mathieu que
faites-vous concernant les jeunes
diplômés aujourd'hui se retrouvant sans
emploi alors il ya d'abord des mesures
qui sont déjà opérationnels pour inciter
à l'embauché des jeunes rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui une entreprise qui
embauche un jeune jusqu'à 26 ans en cdi
peut bénéficier d'une prime de 4000
euros je ne saurais trop inciter les
entreprises à embaucher des jeunes et a
bénéficié de cette prime de 4000 euros
si vous embaucher un apprenti même chose
comme apprenti de plus de 18 ans ce sera
à 8000 euros de prime un apprenti de
moins de 18 ans ce sera cinq mille euros
de prime
au-delà de ces soutiens financiers qui
ont déjà été votée dans le projet de loi
de finances rectificative de juillet
donc c'est tout de suite disponible
s'est tout de suite opérationnel et il
faut que l'entreprise s'en servent le
plus possible nous apportons un soutien
à certains secteurs qui sont
particulièrement touchés et qui du coup
peuvent embaucher des jeunes qui
n'auraient pas embaucher sinon j'ai reçu
ce matin les représentants les secteurs
de l'aéronautique qui est un secteur qui
embauche des centaines de milliers de
personnes et qui est très touché par la
crise et par l'effondrement du transport
aérien
nous avons mis en place des fonds de
soutien qui permettent d'embaucher par
exemple des ingénieurs les jeunes
ingénieurs qui ne trouveraient pas
d'emploi aujourd'hui mais vous avez des
fonds qui permettent de financer des
recherches des travaux de recherche en
aéronautique qui permettent d'embaucher
des jeunes ingénieurs dans le secteur
aéronautique
même chose dans l'industrie automobile
donc nous avons multiplié soit les
dispositifs de primes soient les
dispositifs de soutien sectoriel pour
que un jeune qui sort avec que son
diplôme d'ingénieur en maintenance
l'ingénieur aéronautique d'ingénieurs
dans l'industrie automobile puisse
trouver un emploi aujourd'hui et je
lance un appel à toutes les entreprises
qu'elles soient petites ou qu'elle soit
grande pour qu'elle fasse cet effort
d'embaucher des jeunes keller ou un
espoir qu elle leur ouvre des
perspectives qu'elle se saisisse des
dispositifs du gouvernement
nous avons tous une responsabilité on ne
remontera pas la crise tout seul c'est
pas l'état seul c'est pas les
collectivités locales seul c'est pas les
entreprises seul qui s'en sortiront
c'est la solidarité collective et la
responsabilité collective qui nous
permettront d'apporter des réponses à
mathieu et à tous les jeunes qui
s'inquiètent pour leur emploi
une dernière question internet pour
hélène selon vous est ce que c'est le
bon moment pour créer son entreprise
oui oui et je veux dire elle n louis
c'est le bon moment
c'est le bon moment parce que y'a jamais
le moment idéal
c'est vrai qu'il ya une crise économique
aujourd'hui mais
nous la surmonterons et d'ici quelques
mois je l'espère nous aurons retrouvé un
niveau d'activité satisfaisant
donc oui c'est le bon moment pour créer
son entreprise et je veux dire à hélène
que nous avons besoin d'elle nous avons
besoin de son engagement et que si les
jeunes qui nous écoutent peuvent se dire
bon allez on va quand même tenter notre
chance on va quand même se lancer dans
la création d'entreprise
mais ils feront oeuvre utile et je suis
sûr que ça marchera on passe aux
questions des journalistes
bonsoir messieurs les ministres cela
fait plus d'une dizaine de jours
maintenant qu'il y a des nouvelles
mesures restrictives à aix et marseille
le taux d'incidence a légèrement baissé
vous n'avez pas fait de focus lors de
cette conférence de presse à ce sujet
mais il a légèrement baissé cependant le
nombre de tests a drastiquement diminué
ces dernières semaines on est passé de
2000 puis 110 test pour 100000 habitants
la semaine du 14 au 20 septembre à 1875
tess pour 100000 habitants la semaine
dernière et dans le même temps le taux
de positivité de ces tests a quant à lui
augmenté ce que les mesures fermes et
les bars on en a parlé à l'instant et ce
protocole sanitaire renforcée dans les
restaurants ont suffisamment à vos yeux
porter leurs fruits ou comptez-vous ré
évaluer l'efficacité de ces mesures
assurément nous révélions en permanence
l'efficacité des mesures
d'abord ce ne sont pas des mesures qui
sont prises au doigt mouillé et j'ai
expliqué tout à l'heure pourquoi en
particulier les barres et d'autres
situations qui présentent des risques et
c'est aussi pour ça c'est d'ailleurs
votre question tombe bien c'est aussi
pour ça qu'on ne prend pas forcément des
mesures rétroactives on ne réduit pas
les mesures immédiatement dès qu'on voit
que ça frémit ou qui est un début
d'embellie dans un territoire il faut le
conforter dans la durée et si vous avez
suivi tout à l'heure ce que j'expliquais
si vous allez si vous êtes allé dans un
bar par exemple la semaine dernière
alors pas à marseille en l'occurrence
mais imaginons que soyez allé dans un
bar
peut-être que ça vous êtes arrivé à
paris avant qu'il soit fermé
et bien vous pouvez être aujourd'hui
contagieuse sans savoir peut-être ce
week-end à les rendre visite
un de vos proches
plus vulnérables en tout cas moins
jeunes que vous le contaminer parce que
vous êtes en famille et que vous sentez
encore une fois très fort et penser que
ça va bien vous êtes dans votre cocon
familial habituels et les conséquences
sanitaires sur votre proche
elles se font ressentir dans quinze
jours donc considérer que parce qu'il ya
eu des mesures pour freiner la
circulation du virus renforcée il y a
quinze jours à marseille il y aurait
forcément un impact à mesurer
aujourd'hui c'est être en anticipation
en revanche d'autres mesures avaient été
mises en place à aix marseille et dans
d'autres zones de circulation du virus à
marseille déjà depuis le mois d'août qui
permettent vraisemblablement
d'enregistrer des résultats positifs
on voit arriver sur l'incidence alors
quand le nombre de tests diminue dans
une ville vraisemblablement c'est parce
qu'il ya moins de gens symptomatique qui
vont sur tester l'autre hypothèse ce
serait de considérer qu'on fasse moins
de tests intentionnellement ce qui n'est
absolument pas le cas ni à aix marseille
ni nulle part donc on surveille ça on
regarde l'évolution de l'incidence on
sait que de toute façon le l'impact
sanitaire sur les hôpitaux il a une il a
un effet rémanent dans la durée d'au
moins deux ou trois semaines
même lorsque la courbe d'incidence
commencent à se casser
donc on surveille ça et lorsqu on
prendra des décisions en concertation
avec les élus de réduire les mesures
c'est qu'on aura la certitude que ces
mesures auront été suffisamment efficace
nous l'avons fait collectivement nous
l'avons fait de manière massive national
très ample très dur ça s'appelait le
confinement aujourd'hui nous le faisons
territoire par territoire en fonction de
la situation épidémique en chaque
endroit collectivement et
individuellement dans les efforts et la
solidarité que nous montrons au
quotidien en faisant attention de ne pas
contaminer nos proches notamment les
plus fragiles et ce sera efficace dans
la durée camille collin pour tf1 lci
est ce que les mesures annoncées ce soir
vont suffire à appréhender la période
qu'on s'est compliqué des vacances
scolaires et de la toussaint dans deux
semaines à quoi faut-il s'attendre si la
situation ne s'améliore pas d'ici là est
ce que vous envisagez ait des
restrictions de
déplacement en souvient de la règle des
100 km et très concrètement pour les
gens qui peut être maintenant réserve
des vacances ou essaient de s'organiser
que conseillez-vous est-ce qu'il faut
annuler les vacances c'est ce qu'il faut
se limiter aux départements ou même à la
région à quelle échelle là aussi vous
poser une question extrêmement
importante que beaucoup de français se
posent évidemment et qu'on peut tous se
rencontrer dans notre vie personnelle
moi d'ailleurs à titre personnel comme
la plupart des français dans un parce
que j'aurai des vacances mais parce que
j'ai des enfants et que je me pose la
question des ce qui sera possible de
quitter paris dans quinze jours pour
aller en profite et peut-être quelques
jours je vais vous répondre
nous n'avons pas pris la décision de
limiter la circulation d'une métropole à
une autre plusieurs raisons à cela
d'abord nous ne sommes pas arrivés a
ainsi une situation de diffusion du
virus tel que nous l'avions connus au
printemps dernier lorsque des
restrictions de circulation avait été
prise ensuite parce que si vous regardez
la carte de france et que vous souvenez
des métropoles qui ont été cités en
réalité le virus circule beaucoup dans
la plupart des métropoles à l'exception
de quelques-unes et donc les
circulations d'une zone à l'autre ne
sont pas de nature à les exporter a
amené du virus là où il y en aurait pas
aujourd'hui ça c'est une différence
aussi fondamentale mais puisque vous me
posez la question je vais vous répondre
de la même manière qu'on doit être
extrêmement prudents dans notre
quotidien
il faut rester extrêmement prudent à
l'heure où les vacances viennent je
crois que l'exemple estivale et
notamment du mois d'août doit nous
servir de leçon collectivement on n'est
pas invincible face au virus
on doit vivre on doit évoluer on doit
voir les siens profiter de nos familles
et de nos proches
mais en faisant très attention et les
vacances de la toussaint sont des
vacances qui sont souvent passés en
famille et on va souvent voir les
parents et les grands parents
là mon message il est encore plus fort
protégez vous protéger les vôtres fait
extrêmement attention il pascal moral
monsieur le ministre comment allez vous
procéder
vous avez dit qu'il y at-il à y avoir
des déprogrammations de soins est ce que
ce seront des directives que vous
donnerez quelle pathologie touche rond
tels quels acteurs publics privés
comment allez vous procéder des raies
récemment des associations notamment de
lutte contre le cancer unis cancer la
ligue se sont alarmés sur des soins qui
n'auraient pas été prodigués en temps
voulu comment allez vous faire deuxième
question rapide que pensez vous avez
vous réagi au conseil scientifique de
marseille je ne vous ai pas entendu
répondre à cette question
la loi ne m'a pas regardée d'un conseil
scientifique à marseille parce qu'elle
ne m'a pas été posée la première
question de paray pardon plus importante
que la seconde à laquelle je prête à
vrai dire peu d'attention la
déprogrammation des soins se fait
hôpital par hôpital au printemps dernier
c'était un plan massif de
déprogrammation des soins dans
l'ensemble des hôpitaux du territoire
pour laisser de la place parce que la
vague arrivait et qu'elle n'avait pas pu
être anticipée dans la mesure où le
virus était inconnue et que nous
n'avions pas d'outil de mesure
actuellement nous faisons une
déprogrammation au cas par cas hôpital
par hôpital territoire par territoire
elles ont commencé il ya quinze jours
quand je suis allé justement à marseille
dans un service de réanimation
le service dans lequel vous aviez 14
lits sur 15 occupés par des malades du
co lead était un service de réanimation
neurochirurgicales et de chirurgie
digestive ça veut dire que les places
qui sont utilisées par des malades qui
ont des formes graves du coronavirus ne
sont par définition pas utilisé par des
malades qui aurait dû être opéré ou du
cerveau ou de l'abdomen
c'est ça la déprogrammation et quand on
dit qu'on peut passer de 5000 à douze
mille lits de réanimation pour
accueillir des malades ducobu c'est au
détriment des malades qui n'ont pas le
coc vide c'est des programmations je le
redis ce fonds hôpital par hôpital
l'ile-de-france bien déclencher le plan
blanc je le disais tout à l'heure
ce qui veut dire que les
déprogrammations vont prendre une
ampleur plus importante encore nous
souhaitons qu'elles soient les plus
courte possible parce que nous ne
pouvons pas nous permettre de faire
prendre du retard de soins à des
milliers de malades qui ont besoin de se
faire opérer
nous prenons encore deux questions
céline moncel bfm tv bonsoir l'île de
france doit se préparer à une marée très
forte ça c'est ce que nous dit
aujourd'hui le directeur de l'agencé
régionale de santé
si la situation en ile de france elle
venait encore à se dégrader
est ce que la région pourrait basculer
en zone d'état d'urgence sanitaire quels
seraient les critères de cet état
d'urgence sanitaire est ce que c'est
synonyme de confinement locales et puis
ma deuxième question
elle concerne les bars et les
restaurants je crois que le critère qui
a été retenue c'est
les établissements qui possède une
cuisine peuvent rester ouverts et à bfm
tv on a constaté qu'il y avait pas mal
le établissements qui étaient un peu
perdus par exemple des restos où on
impose aux clients de consommer un plat
pour pouvoir prendre un verre etc
avez vous été suffisamment clair sur
cette question et se distingue au bar
restaurant est il pertinent sur la
première question que vous posez sur
l'île de france les critères j'ai été
présentée tout à l'heure si un
territoire arrive à une saturation très
important des réanimations par des
malades atteints du coronavirus on a
parlé de 60% 60% aujourd'hui en
ile-de-france est un peu moins de 40%
mais effectivement le directeur général
de la grèce a raison de dire que ça va
vite mais nous avons alerté semaine
après semaine pour dire que ça risquait
de monter si on arrivait à 60% l'état
d'urgence sanitaire peut s'accompagner
d'autres mesures visant à freiner la
diffusion du virus qui serait alors
discuté en décider en conseil de défense
et sécurité nationale et discuter avec
les élus le préfet les autorités locales
pour tenir compte de la situation propre
à chaque territoire avec des fermetures
de commerces non essentiels j'imagine
des mesures qui sonde a par ailleurs
parfois appliquée chez des voisins je
pense à l'espagne pense à l'angleterre
pensait la belgique aux pays bas qui
font face parfois des situations très
compliquées
mon message n'est pas de vous dire on va
vers ça mon message idée de vous dire si
on est vigilant et si on fait attention
au virus faut pas vivre dans la peur et
j'ai perdu pleinement conscience que ces
messages répétés toutes les semaines ils
ont un côté anxiogène sur les français
qui ont partagé entre la peur du virus
et la peur de perdre l'emploi
l'idée n'est pas de rendre les gens que
j'aime l'idée d'armer les gens de
connaissances et d'outils pour lutter
avec efficacité contre la propagation du
virus
quand on ne connaît pas un ennemi non
seulement on en a peur mais on n'est pas
efficace quand on connaît son ennemi et
qu'on sait comment lutter chacun d'entre
nous peut lutter contre la diffusion du
virus parce que nous l'avons déjà fait
et nous l'avons fait avec succès et même
en dehors du confinement en mayenne cet
été
en guyane alors nous sommes capables de
lutter contre l'épidémie et d'éviter les
situations sanitaires tels que vous
celle que vous abordez donc je ne veux
pas faire de projections plus avant ce
que nous voulons notre objectif c'est de
ne pas arriver à nous poser la question
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire même
territorialisées et là votre deuxième
question je crois que tu es sur les bars
et des restaurants
cette fois-ci brune
ou les sur la différenciation entre les
restaurants vous me disiez et les bars
est-ce que c'est suffisamment clair il
ya un protocole qui a été rédigé par le
haut conseil de santé publique qui est
je dirais presque aussi précis que des
protocoles qui ont pu être faits dans
d'autres domaines dans d'autres secteurs
ils ont été présentés aux différentes
fédérations représentatives des bars et
des restaurants qui sont me semble-t-il
assez clair qui même qu'on perles comme
comporte un certain nombre de détails
comme le fait que la musique de deux ne
doit pas être trop forte pour ne pas
être amené à parler trop fort parce
qu'on projette plus de virus quand on
parle fort mais ça peut faire sourire
mais enfin c est parfois des moyens très
simples et des mesures très pratiques
qui permettent d'être efficace dans la
lutte contre le virus
solène le n france info pour les villes
qui arrive en catégorie zone d' alerte
renforcée zone d'alerté maximale est ce
que les nouvelles restrictions des âmes
du matin seront automatiquement les
mêmes que les villes qui sont déjà dans
ces catégories c'est à dire les
restrictions sur les bars les
restaurants les piscines et
rassemblements ou est-ce que tu râles
fruit d'une négociation avec les élus
d'une concertation et dans ce cas là
quand aura-t-on analyse des restrictions
il faut tenir compte des situations
locales et par exemple vous parlez des
piscines il y as est un exemple parmi
d'autres mais qui a montré que certaines
piscines pouvait rester ouverte et
d'autres pouvaient fermer et qui avait
une territorialisation qui pouvait être
différente certaines mesures sont
d'application automatique quand on parle
de la fermeture des bars à 22h dans les
zones d'alerté renforcé la fermeture des
bars et le protocole sanitaire renforcée
dans les restaurants ça va concerner
toutes les zones d'alerté maximale la
concertation est aussi importante pour
définir avec les élus locaux
le périmètre précis du territoire qui
est concerné c'est pas simple il faut
regarder commune par commune
il faut regarder si quelqu'un qui la
population qui habite telle ville est
amené à voyager dans la ville d'à côté
donc il faut être capable d'avoir des
mesures suffisamment englobante pour
être efficace sur un territoire mais
sans être excessif pour ne pas pénaliser
inutilement des commerçants et des
usagers de communes qui sont moins
soumises à la pression épidémique
quand on parle de concertation et
d'applications c'est que les arrêtés qui
sont pris par les préfets et qui porte
application des mesures que j'ai
annoncée sont définis écrit en lien avec
les élus
après vous avez des élus vous savez on
en a rencontré beaucoup premier ministre
on a rencontré beaucoup j'étais présent
avec lui beaucoup comprennent la plupart
comprennent
très grande majorité comprennent
accompagne les mesures et vont même
parfois au delà en prenant localement
des mesures pour freiner davantage la
situation
la diffusion du virus pour d'autres il
ya un travail d'explication qu'il faut
reprendre régulièrement et en définitive
comme l'indiqué à juste titre le premier
ministre l'état est garant de la
sécurité et de la santé des français
et lorsqu'un accord ne peut pas être
trouvée que ce soit sur des discussions
sur des chiffres ou la nature du virus
qui serait moins dangereux ici ou là où
que ce soit sur des questions plus
cohérente de capacité de la population à
accueillir telle ou telle mesure
eh bien l'état prend ses responsabilités
dernière question la campagne de
frédérique prabonnaud france télévisions
la campagne de vaccination grippe
commence la semaine prochaine
est ce que vous envisagez de demander au
pharmacien de donner une priorité aux
personnes les plus fragiles
et est ce que vous craignez des tensions
sur les stocks de vaccins grippe cet
hiver nous avons commandé beaucoup plus
de vaccins que les années précédentes
faut savoir que les commandes de vaccins
se font en décembre de l'année précédant
la campagne vaccinale et se termine en
avril la campagne vaccinale va commencer
le 13 octobre et ne commence pas pour
les français le 13 octobre
elle commence pour les publics
vulnérables et les soignants qui sont
les personnes les plus fragiles au
regard de la grippe sont les personnes
qui font des formes graves
j'invite à travers votre question et la
réponse
j'invite vraiment les soignants dans les
hôpitaux les ehpad et en ville à se
faire vacciner contre la grippe
c'est fondamental c'est moins vous que
vous protégez que les patients dont vous
prenez soin et c'est indispensable de ne
pas transmettre la grippe parce que la
grippe peut faire aussi beaucoup de
ravages et notamment dans les milieux
fragiles hospitaliers et les ehpad et
puis les publics vulnérables
ils reçoivent des bons de l'assurance
maladie pour la plupart d'entre eux on y
ajoute les femmes enceintes qui sont
repérés parfois par leur médecin ou dans
les pharmacies par exemple et reçoivent
un bon pour pouvoir bénéficier
gratuitement du vaccin contre la grippe
nous voulons qu'un maximum de personnes
de ces publics vulnérables et de ses
soignants bénéficie la vaccination
qu'avec une couverture qui est beaucoup
trop faible notre pays beaucoup trop
faible pour tous les autres déjà un
premier message c'est que la grippe elle
n'arrive pas dans deux semaines
habituellement elles arrivent plus tôt à
la fin du mois de décembre et ce que
nous disent des épidémiologistes qui
font le constat de la situation
l'épidémie grippale dans l'hémisphère
sud qui est donc déjà passé c'est que la
grippe est plutôt retardé par la
présence du co vide
donc il ne rien ne sert de courir en
pharmacie ceux qui doivent courir en
pharmacie n'ont pas courir mais aller se
faire vacciner dans les bonnes
conditions ses parts à partir du 13
octobre
ce sont les publics vulnérables et
effectivement des pharmacies sont
invitées à privilégier ce public là
d'autant que quelqu'un qui comme vous et
moi en pleine santé se ferait vacciner
en octobre contre la grippe n'aurait pas
une protection à béret contre le virus
qui contracteraient au mois de janvier
merci
oh